Wilkiewicz: Hello, everyone.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz,
and I work for YouTube.
I'm a developer advocate.
Um, I have Greg Schechter
and Jeffrey Posnick
here with me today.
And, uh, we'll talk about, uh,
YouTube iframe player
and the future of embedding.
So thank you very much
for coming.
Um, there's another one
offered today.
Um, we will talk about,
you know,
what the iframe player is
and why we introduced it.
Really what is the problem
that we were trying to solve?
Um, Greg will cover, uh,
HTML5 Video Playback,
some of the challenges
that he has faced
implementing the player,
as well as the actual API, um,
design and implementation.
So if you're thinking
about introducing
you're own JavaScript-based API
on top of an iframe,
he'll highlight
some design choices
that--that you might consider
in your own designs.
Uh, we'll talk a little bit more
about, you know,
what are the differences
between the, um,
iframe JavaScript API
that we expose now
and the existing ActionScript 3
JavaScript API,
and what this means
to application developers.
And then finally,
Jeff created a very nice
sample player application
for this occasion.
And he will walk you through
the implementation
of--of his HTML5-based,
uh, video player,
so that you could reuse
that code
in your own applications.
Uh, before we start,
um, if you would like to
live-tweet about this session,
here are the hash tags--
#io2011, #YouTube.
And then we would like you
to submit some feedback for us.
The QR code is right here
and the show uplink
as well on this page.
So, uh, you know,
this is the summary
of the session, really.
Uh, you know,
what we're trying to do
is--is to let the embed,
not the embedder
figure out the complexity
of web video.
Uh, so as you all know,
what we're facing
is really a platform-
fragmentation problem right now.
There's a lot of new platforms,
new operating systems
coming online,
especially in the--
in the mobile space,
so then in order to provide,
um, platform-independent
portable video playback,
uh, the embedder actually
is facing quite a few choices.
And we're trying to simplify
this complexity.
So, uh, as I mentioned, both--
you know, we see new platforms,
and the encoding standards
supported by these
platforms also vary.
So we have H.263 to H.264,
uh, WebM VP8, and so forth.
And then the actual
embed technology
also, um, is different
depending on the platform.
So historically
we had AS2--AS2.
Um, there's some RTSP streaming
support for feature phones
that we still have,
AS3, HTML5.
So all that actually adds
complexity
whenever one wants to include
video in a web page
or web application
or a native application.
So the problem that we're
trying to solve here
is to really provide
a simple embed
that will work across
all the range of platforms
and hopefully future-proof
the embed,
so once you embed a video
in your application once,
as new platforms come online,
we'll take the responsibility
of making sure
that the video playback
is really designed
for that platform,
works well,
and you don't get a black box
saying, you know,
you need to install this
or that plug-in and so forth.
In the lower left
I have a syntax example
of the iframe player,
so for those of you
who have used it before,
it should be pretty familiar.
For those of you that haven't,
one thing to notice--
there's nothing here
about the underlying
video implementation technology.
So just by putting
that snippet of code
in your web application,
web page, whatever,
uh, the only thing
it instructs us to do
is to actually choose
the optimal
video playback technology
for your device
with an encoding that your
device can actually support
and play the video back,
so you really don't have
to worry about the complexity.
Uh, so next we'll talk
a little bit more
about the design decisions
that drove the iframe player
implementation,
as well as, you know,
how we ended up
exposing the player API
to application developers,
much like what we have done
with the Flash player
in the past.
So now I will hand it off
to Greg,
who--who will dig
into the details.
Schechter: Thanks, Jarek.
Uh, so I'm Greg Schechter.
I'm one of the engineers
that works on the HTML5 player
and the iframe embed.
And, uh, you know, HTML5--
it's new. It's awesome.
You've been seeing
all these cool demos.
But Flash has sort of been
in the business
for quite some time.
Uh, so we kind of
wondered, like,
why should we build
this HTML5 player?
We've got this great Flash one.
Uh, you know, what makes
HTML5 better?
And so we looked--we took a look
at, like, both platforms,
and we looked at performance,
accessibility,
something I call
"device-ability,"
and all sorts of things,
and tried to compare
the two, uh, platforms.
So the first thing
we sort of looked at
is, like,
the different features.
Uh, what does Flash provide,
and what does HTML5
have as well?
So one of the first things
that's really important
that Flash has
was robust video streaming.
In order to provide
this really great,
excellent user experience,
we need to have, uh,
fine control over buffering
and being able to change
the quality.
Uh, we also want
to be able to jump
to any part of the video,
when the user's seeking.
And HTML5 doesn't quite have
this fine-tuning yet.
Another important thing
is content protection.
Uh, we don't own
all of our contents.
Uh, you might have heard
that, uh, we just launched
all these great video rentals.
And, uh, we've got to make sure
that our content is secure.
And so, uh, Flash has
a protocol for this,
RTMPE, that's, like,
built in, easy to do.
And HTML5 doesn't have
an accepted standard
for this yet.
After that,
the sort of full screen--
uh, when I'm watching
my favorite cat videos,
one thing that's
really important
is I want them full screen
and in HD.
And, uh, we--
we don't really have
an API to do this yet.
WebKit does have something
in its nightlies.
And, uh, and the code for that
is actually pretty simple.
It works pretty well.
Uh, and so it looks
a little bit like this.
You can grab any elements.
Uh, so in our case,
we'd grab our video player.
And we would request
that it goes to full screen.
And then once it gets triggered,
we can do
whatever we want with it,
you know, make it larger,
change our buttons,
and--and so forth.
And so eventually,
because this is in WebKit,
this will be available
in Chrome hopefully very soon.
Uh, another thing
that's important
is camera and microphone access.
A lot of our users come to--
come to YouTube,
and they just want to film,
uh, talking to, you know,
the--the millions of viewers,
uh, right there.
And, uh, HTML5
doesn't have this yet.
Uh, but Flash--
you know, it's there.
Another interesting thing
is formats.
So with Flash,
it's pretty much gonna--
if--if the device
supports Flash,
you can play your Flash videos
without any issues.
Uh, HTML5--we actually
have to support
two different formats.
We have H.264 and WebM.
And so browsers, uh,
some browsers will support both.
At the moment,
Chrome will support both.
But you know, then you get
browsers like Firefox,
which will only support WebM,
and IE, which will
only support H.264.
Now we have, uh, all of our
videos are encoded in H.264,
and most of them
are in WebM at the moment.
But it's taken a while, 'cause
it's such a large database
to get through and make
all these additional encodings.
Uh, so now why is HTML5
so great?
And, uh, it's--we've got
this open-source technology--
open source browsers,
players, and codecs,
which really allows
for some great, uh,
development in the space,
and making it really fast-paced
and changing really quickly.
It also should have
lower latency
when we're watching
these videos.
We don't have to start up
this plug-in.
It's just native in the browser.
It should be a lot faster.
And this is really evident,
uh, in the iframe,
which I'll--I'll show later.
And, uh, so we're--we're hoping
for better performance,
uh, with these
different encodings.
Uh, we were hoping to get better
performance for the videos
and just fidelity.
Just it works smoother
without worrying
about our code screwing up
the video playback.
Another great thing
is accessibility.
And, uh, there's a few other
accessibility talks here
that go into some
really detailed stuff here.
Um, one of the--the talks
that happened earlier
which was great
was all about captions.
And, um, you know,
I really like having captions
on my--on my cat videos.
This is one of my favorite
comic strips there.
But, um, so one of the features
that's important to me
is actually navigating,
uh, in the browser.
And because it's native,
I can just tab around
in the page.
So let me show you
a quick demo.
Um, so this is the--
you know, this is YouTube,
and I got the Flash player here.
And I start
tabbing around the page,
and, uh, eventually I'm trying
to get into the player,
but I just sort of jump
below it, and I'm--
my tab focus is down here
at the moment--
um, and I can't get
into the player.
But if I click my mouse on it,
um, you know, I'll--
I'll give focus to the player.
and then I can tab around
and use the controls,
um, but I'm trapped.
I can't get outside.
I can't start to interact
with the rest of the page again.
One of the great things
that's great about HTML5
is, uh, I can tab around
in the page,
and then I can jump
right into the player,
and I can use my keyboard
to start playing the video.
Um, and then if, you know,
I want to move on
to the rest of the page,
I can just continue
to tab around,
and, uh, and I'm out
interacting with the page again.
And so, um, you know,
different user agents
are gonna have, um,
have to build, uh, APIs
for having these--
this special video handling,
uh, for these--
for the video tag.
Um, but then screen readers,
any screen reader you have
will be able to access that,
and you'll have, you know,
accessible videos.
Uh, so next thing
I want to talk about
is device-ability.
And that's--basically
what I mean by that is
where do these platforms
that work in Flash--
where can you watch
Flash videos,
and where can you watch
HTML5 videos?
And at the moment,
when we look at our
HTML5-capable browsers,
uh, you know,
we've got just under 40%
of, uh, of browser usage
is HTML5-capable.
Uh, Chrome
is really kicking butt
in this space as well.
And a very small percentage
of this is mobile.
So the world kinda
looks like this.
There's all these places
that support Flash,
uh, a good chunk
that also support HTML5,
and this tiny sliver--
and this is exaggerated
a little bit--
that only do HTML5,
and that's mostly iPhone
and iPad.
There's a few other
random things
that are in there as well.
Uh, but then what's
really interesting
is when we look
at actual usage of people
who are getting access
to our APIs,
our YouTube APIs, and where
they're playing videos,
uh, it actually kind of
shifts opposite.
Uh, most of the places
are actually on devices
that don't have Flash.
Uh, so that's, like,
you know, really great
that, uh, we need
this HTML5 support there.
Uh, so we were asking
why HTML5,
but it's really about when
we should be using HTML5,
uh, 'cause we clearly see
that it's--
it's needed in many places.
Uh, so our first primary goal
about building this player
was we wanted
to recover playbacks
that would have been lost
without Flash.
And so our solution for this,
uh, to make it real easy,
was to have this iframe embed.
So you know,
like we showed earlier,
the code for it is very simple.
You just plop in the--
the video ID,
and, uh, and you're good to go
without having to worry,
uh, about anything.
And so this has, you know,
great advantages,
because it gives our user
HTML5 or Flash
based on the device
and the user's preferences.
It allows for so much better
mobile support.
And it gives us this
"just works" experience.
Uh, so just a little bit
about how you would get
the HTML5 player.
Uh, at the moment,
you can opt in,
uh, to getting the player.
And if you go
to youtube.com/html5,
you can join the experiment.
And if you're trying to view
these videos on a device
that doesn't support Flash,
you'll also be opted in
automatically.
And, uh, so the first thing
we do is we check,
all right, does your browser
support HTML5?
And the code for that
is pretty simple.
We just create a video tag,
and we see--
can we play the two formats
I mentioned?
Uh, so the first one is H.264,
and the second one is WebM.
Now not a lot of our, uh,
not a lot of our embeds
actually get clicked on to play,
so we don't load all the data
about the video yet.
So we don't know
if we have both formats,
uh, when we--
when we load the video.
Uh, so that's why we have
to check both at the start.
Um, after that, we wait
for the user to click play.
We fetch this information.
And then we say, all right,
are there any business reasons
that we can't play the video,
um, the details of which
are not all that important?
Um, but if we--if it's great,
if we can play this video,
then we're gonna look
and we'll see,
do we have, uh,
a format that's available,
uh, that this browser can play?
And if yes, great,
we're winning.
Otherwise we're gonna fall back.
We're gonna go
to that Flash player,
or we're gonna fail out if your
device doesn't support it.
Uh, so the next thing--
once we have these two players,
we can look at performance
between the two.
And, uh, so the first thing we--
the first one--
pretty much one of the most
important things
is the player start time.
And this is the time,
uh, just so that it looks
like the player's happening.
Uh, maybe you--like,
on the main page you see,
like, the little loading icon,
or at times you'll see
the thumbnail,
um, on the--
on the iframe embed.
And so you know, it's the first
cue that the user has
that's something's working,
something's interacting.
And at the moment,
we can see HTML5
is just a lot--
you know, a lot faster.
It's a full second--
a full half a second faster,
which is great.
Um, and so I pulled out, like,
this little,
uh, strip line thing
that--that's got
all these photos.
And this was
in a controlled environment,
and the times got
exaggerated a little bit.
Um, but the comparison
is pretty accurate
about how much faster
the HTML5 player is
just to show
that initial thumbnail.
And so, uh, I want to--
I want to show you it,
uh, in action now.
So I've got, uh,
the two players here.
The top one's the Flash player,
and the bottom one's
the HTML5 player.
And, uh, when I reload
the page,
we can see that the HTML5 player
comes in a lot faster,
which is great.
And then when I actually go
to play the video,
uh, sometimes...
Chen: Hi, everyone,
My name is Steve Chen.
Schechter: Um...
Chen: I'm one of the co-owners
of YouTube, and I run
the engineering team here.
Schechter: I don't know.
Stearns: Hi, my name's
Jeff Stearns--
Schechter: I don't know
what's going on
with the Flash player today,
but that's another reason
I like the HTML5 player more.
[laughter]
Schechter: Um, but you can
see that the, um,
the HTML5 player started
a little bit faster.
And I actually think
that I just got lucky there,
'cause a lot of times
the Flash player
will start first,
um, so we're still sort of
tweaking performance on our end.
Um, one of the advantages
that the Flash player has
is because all the formats
are the same,
it sort of can take advantage
of caching those formats
a little bit better.
Um...
Uh, so the next thing is,
like, you know--
that I want to talk about
is the details
of our new JavaScript API
and how, you know,
you control the player.
And so since we have this new--
this new way to embed videos,
this iframe embed,
you know, we had to write
a new API to interact with it.
So the most important thing
was about communication.
We don't have this object
in the--
we don't have an object
in the DOM anymore,
uh, that we could just, like,
add things to directly.
So, uh, we had to think of a way
that this API could communicate
with the player and this iframe.
So the first thing we thought of
was to pull the URL fragment.
So that's just a little, uh,
fragment at the end of the URL.
And you can--you can update it.
It won't cause the page
to refresh.
And there were a couple
problems with this.
Uh, the messages
are very one-dimensional,
so it's hard to send
complex messages.
Uh, polling is gonna eat up
your CPU,
and it's not gonna be
instantaneous,
uh, 'cause you're being--you're
gonna have to set a timer.
And, uh, then you have, like,
of different timers conflicting,
and it's just a little bit
of a hassle to manage.
Uh, and then the really
difficult part
is since both directions
of communication, uh,
sending messages to the player,
and the player sending messages
back out the page--
have this--have to use
the same fragment.
And so then you run
into issues--all right, our--
you know, am I reading data,
or am I writing data?
Am I overwriting data
I haven't read?
And it just gets
very complicated.
Um, so instead we decided
to use the postMessage API.
Now this isn't available
in as many browsers
as just being able to pull
that fragment,
um, but it works a lot simpler.
And the majority of our--
of our users
will be able to use,
um, postMessage
to communicate with the player.
So it's very simple.
Uh, basically
you have a window.
You just send a message,
um, and you specify the--
the target of your message.
And so, uh, we basically
can use JSON
to encode and decode
our messages,
so it's very native
to the browser.
Uh, we don't have
polling anymore,
uh, so we can use the native
event listeners to communicate.
And, uh, the communication
is sandboxed per window.
So, uh, you know,
they're using
different channels,
but now all the messages
are being sent
to the parent windows.
So if you have multiple players
on the page,
it gets a little complicated,
but we were able to, uh,
easily, you know, differentiate
between the different play--
iframes on the page.
And one interesting thing is
the calls are now asynchronous,
uh, so if you wanted
to read data from the player,
uh, you know, you might have
to wait some time.
so instead we just store
the player--
the player state for you.
And so when you interact
with the player,
you'll get those--you'll get
that data that you want,
uh, right away.
Uh, so now I'm gonna hand it
back over to Jarek,
who'll talk about, uh,
comparing the iframe API
to the AS3 player API.
Wilkiewicz: Thanks, Greg.
So Greg went through
the design decisions
that went
into the API implementation.
And I wanted to talk
a little bit about, you know,
what this means
for an application developer
that is used to interacting
with our player API
in the AS3 world
and what the differences are,
how you can take advantage
of the new API
and what other things
to watch out for.
And then, you know, to prove
that it is in fact possible
to use the API and create
very interesting experiences
around YouTube Video Playback,
Jeff is going to follow up
with his example
after my, uh, part.
So for those of you that have
worked with the player API,
uh, you know,
this is very straightforward,
but I just wanted to refresh
your memory.
So there are three ways
in which YouTube Video Playback
can be controlled
by an application developer--
through player parameters,
ActionScript API,
and JavaScript API.
So let's walk
through the three mechanisms
and see how they differ
if you are interacting
with the Flash
versus HTML5 player.
Um, so when it comes
to player parameters,
there's really two cases.
One is--down the line
video implementation
is based on Flash.
And again, the decision
that drives this
is something that Greg
has described before,
so he had this nice,
uh, decision tree
that was deciding
whether to, uh,
start HTML5 Video Playback
versus Flash Playback.
So if it's actually
Flash Playback,
then all the player parameters
that you are used
to taking advantage of--
it's just passed through.
So they work just like before.
And here's an example
of a player parameter.
This one will trigger the video
to start playback
as soon as somebody navigates
onto a page
where the embed is present.
Uh, if the underlying
implementation
is based on HTML5 video,
then we are subject
to some of the limitations,
uh, that Greg has described
as well as some of the features
that we haven't frankly
implemented quite yet.
Uh, so here's a--
you know, an overview
of things that, uh, are--
fall into these two categories.
I'll just walk
through them quickly.
Uh, one thing to watch out for,
um, on iOS
is the autoplay
player parameter.
It's not really honored,
so if somebody embeds a video,
and then an iOS device
navigates to it,
uh, then the user
actually has to confirm
the playback selection.
And I guess it's just to protect
somebody's data plan
from getting taxed.
Even though
the application developer
would like the video to start
playing right away,
iOS will not let that happen
until the user selects play.
Uh, caption support--
our HTML5 player
does display captions,
but there are some categories
that we haven't implemented yet.
For example, the ASR captions
are not, uh, shown yet,
but this is something that is
under active implementation.
Uh, full screen support
is not quite there yet.
Uh, the limiting factor here
is the browser standardization.
And Greg mentioned, uh,
the work that is done
for WebKit to make that
available,
and hopefully you will see that
across the board,
but don't count on it yet.
Uh, annotations--another
very popular YouTube feature,
is not implemented
by the HTML5 player.
Uh, I expect Greg
to start doing that
as soon as he gets back to
his office after this session,
because it's
a very popular feature.
People have done
amazing work with it.
And then finally,
related videos--
uh, you know,
if you watch a YouTube video,
uh, at the end of the playback
you will see a bunch
of videos that we think
are of interest to you.
Uh, that functionality
can be disabled,
uh, through the rel parameter.
Uh, that is something we don't
have in HTML5 player yet.
Um, so next let's talk
about the ActionScript API.
So--so for those of you
that have built, um,
custom Flash players,
um, what typically
people do is--
we actually offer
a Chromeless player
that is based on, uh, AS3.
That player has an API
that can then be used
in a Flash application.
And then you can build
your own experience
around the core YouTube
Video Playback experience.
So if you don't like, you know,
the way our controls look,
any kind of aspect
of the user experience,
you have full control over that,
and just invoke API methods.
So, uh, you know,
for the purpose of this talk,
this is not, you know,
entirely applicable,
because, uh, we're talking about
the iframe API,
and the only API
that we expose to the iframe
is actually an HTML, um,
JavaScript-based API.
One thing to note is, um...
you know, in the new world
of mobile devices
that may not necessarily
support, uh, Flash--
you know, iOS is
a good example of that.
For those of you that are
building applications
that get mobile use,
you know, you probably noticed
that this is a very
nicely growing area.
For everybody, mobile
applications are quite hot.
Uh, so you know,
if you invested time
in building a Flash-based player
around our Chromeless player,
the bad news is some platforms
will not support it.
So all you will get
is a black box.
Uh, so it's a little bit
of a bummer.
Jeff has a remedy for that,
as he will show
later in the session.
But this is one of the things
that--that you run into,
and very quickly if you actually
build mobile applications.
And people that have devices
that don't support, uh,
the Flash technology
actually navigate to your page
that has a very nicely crafted
custom player
that you have built that--
you know, it no longer works.
Uh, so you know,
instead of that,
what you can do is use
our JavaScript API
for the iframe player.
And, uh... whoops.
Um, let's just quickly go
through the differences
between the AS3
JavaScript player API
and the iframe
JavaScript player API.
So there's three operations,
three categories
that I would like to describe--
the player init,
the actual methods
that we expose,
and the event handling.
So player init
is quite different
between the, um,
AS3-based player
and the iframe player.
I have a side-by-side example.
Hopefully you can see that.
But, uh, really,
on the left-hand side
you see the new, uh,
JavaScript-based API usage
that we exposed.
You can load the API library
asynchronously
and then create instances
of YT.Player,
which is really
the player object
that allows you to then control
the player behavior.
When you instantiate the player,
you can specify a video ID
that you would like to load,
as well as any player parameter
and, uh, event handlers.
So there's a set of events
that we allow application
developers to subscribe to.
If you would like to do that,
you can actually specify
the handlers for these events
right when you
instantiate the player.
And on the right-hand side,
this is the, uh,
old-school AS3 JavaScript API
initialization,
uh, using the SWFObject
to load the Chromeless
player library.
And the event handling
is actually done
through DOM event registration.
It's slightly different.
Uh, that method also works
in--in, uh,
the iframe player
JavaScript API,
but now we have
a convenience way of--
convenient way
of creating the handlers
right when the player
is instantiated.
Um, so when it comes
to the actual
core player functionality,
um, there is five
kind of major groups
of operations that we expose.
So queuing functions would allow
you to load video, queue video.
Uh, playback controls,
player settings--
you know, you can set
the volume of the player,
navigate to a specific
time stamp in the player.
Uh, playback status operations
that tell you more
about, you know,
the actual--what's happening
in the actual video.
Uh, playback quality--
so you can actually, uh,
override the selection
that we make
on behalf of the user, um,
when it comes to, you know,
what is the optimal,
uh, resolution
that we should be trying
to, uh, stream to the user.
So, uh, by default we actually
try to detect, you know,
what is the device capability?
What is the size of the window?
And then, you know, for example,
if HD doesn't make sense,
we won't be trying
to ship HD--HD.
But if you want to override it,
you can do that
programmatically.
Uh, and then finally,
uh, we provide
some additional
metadata information,
such as the duration
of the video,
the embed code for the video
through the API.
So comparing these two groups
of operations,
really everything works
pretty much the same.
Uh, the playback status
is the only area
where we still have
some work to do,
so right now
the getVideoBytesTotal
returns a hard-coded 1,000.
Uh, and that is hopefully
going to change in the future.
But other than that, you know,
all the other operations
pretty much work the same.
Um...
So a quick note
about event handling.
Uh, as I mentioned previously,
uh, the way you initial--
initialize the handlers
is slightly different,
uh, but the actual, uh,
semantics are very similar.
The only note
that I wanted to make
is that, uh,
today if you are counting
on the YT.PlayerState.BUFFERING
event
or the state to be
actually delivered to you,
we don't actually generate
that yet in HTML5 player.
So if the underlying
video playback
is based on HTML5,
you will never actually see
that, uh, state.
Other than that, uh,
there are some, you know,
syntactical differences
with respect
to event registration.
So the AS3 player API
relied on the kind of typical
DOM-based registration,
whereas for
the HTML5 player API,
uh, what we recommend is using
the event registration
that is conveniently
possible through--
as a part of the player init.
And, uh, one note
that I wanted to make
is that if you would like
to, uh, kind of play around
with the API,
for those of you that have used
Chrome Console,
uh, you know all about it.
But for those of you
that haven't,
uh, you can very easily,
you know, learn more
about, you know,
what these, uh, methods are
and, uh, invoke them
and so forth,
using the console
right from the browser window.
Just again, a quick way
to get up to speed
on, you know,
all the functionality
that is exposed.
And I believe we have
actually a session about, uh,
Chrome Dev Tools at I/O.
So if you haven't caught it,
that's a good recording
to catch up on later.
Okay, uh, next I will
hand it off to Jeff.
And Jeff will talk about
his experience with the API
and prove to you
that you can in fact build
very interesting video
experiences around YouTube
using the new, uh,
JavaScript API
and HTML5 Video Playback.
Posnick: Thanks, Jarek.
Um, so I'm a member
of the YouTube
API developer relations team.
And part of my job
is to help developers
use these APIs,
so I certainly wanted
to familiarize myself
with the iframe player API.
And, uh,
this example application
I'm gonna show off
is, uh, something that I did
to get familiar with the API,
but also, um,
just hopefully something
that will help you guys learn.
And I wanted to share
some best practices
that I picked up
while writing code
that hopefully I'll be able
to share with you.
So this example, uh, provides
basic YouTube
feed player functionality.
Uh, and what I mean by that--
uh, think of it
kind of like a playlist player,
but instead of only playing back
YouTube playlists,
you can play back
any feed of videos.
And it's powered
by the YouTube Data API.
Uh, this is kind of
a separate set
of restful APIs
that can be used for interacting
with YouTube
in a variety of ways.
One of the ways
is to retrieve feeds of videos.
So you can, uh,
for instance,
plug in a search term
and get back a list
of all the videos
on YouTube that match
that search term,
or you can get back a list
of videos that are uploaded
in given users' accounts,
for instance.
So this particular example,
uh, makes use
of some modern web technologies,
as you might expect.
Uh, there's a bit
of HTML5 in there.
Uh, a lot of JavaScript
is going on under the hood
for interacting
with the iframe player API.
And you know, there's some CSS
as well.
And, um, hopefully, you know,
as I said, this is useful
in its own right.
Feel free to take a look
at the code
and, uh, you know,
use it and adapt it
in your own applications.
But you know, my main purpose
was to illustrate,
um, some iframe player usage
best practices.
So I just want to talk
in a little bit more detail
about the different components
that go into this demo.
Uh, obviously on the HTML5
side of things,
the video element
is quite important.
It can be used
for the supported videos.
And this again is based
on that kind of flow chart
that Greg was
going over earlier.
Um, so assuming a given video
that we attempt to play
can be played back
in the HTML5 video element,
it's going to use that.
And we're actually using
some of the player parameters
that Jarek was talking about,
uh, in this case specifically
the controls=0 player parameter.
So this is gonna give us
a version
of the, uh,
YouTube HTML5 video player
that doesn't have
a type of--
I guess "Chrome"
is the term that we use for it.
It doesn't have
the standard play button.
It doesn't have the seek bar.
It just gives us
the video playback.
And, uh, you know, we're going
to actually implement
the specific playback
functionality
in HTML5 and CSS and so on.
So, uh, to that point
we're using SVG,
which is scalable
vector graphics,
and that's just used
in a fairly straightforward way,
just for implementing
the pause and play buttons
in our example.
And we're making use
of <input type='range'>.
Uh, this is a fairly new
input element
that can be used
for doing scroll controls,
more or less.
So, um, you'll see it
in a little bit
when I show you the example.
But this is something
that allows you to drag
and select a new value
for a given control.
So Google Chrome currently
supports all those features
that we're using,
which is great,
because that's what I'm using
to demo this.
But, uh, some browsers offer
just a subset,
um, and in particular
there's not a lot of support
for <input type='range'>,
um, in a wide number
of browsers right now.
And that'll probably change
over time,
but at the same time, you know,
feel free to, you know,
adapt this and use
something different.
There's plenty
of open-source libraries
for doing slider controls.
Uh, that would
certainly work as well.
Uh, as you might imagine,
there's quite a bit
of JavaScript involved
in writing this sort of example.
Uh, I'm using jQuery
just as a matter
of personal preference
for doing a lot of
kind of the heavy lifting.
And one of the things that's
nice about jQuery in particular
is that it simplifies
the interaction
with the YouTube Data API.
Um, I'm not gonna
actually focus too much
on the interaction
with YouTube Data API,
but I definitely recommend
looking at the code,
if you are curious
as to how you can write
a web application
that will, you know,
do read-only requests
to YouTube,
get the results back,
and display them in some way.
Uh, so it's actually
gonna be using JSON-P
under the hood,
which is a method
of dynamically inserting
a script tag into a page
and having that script tag
point to a URL
basically on their servers.
And the server knows
to respond back
with kind of a wrapper
that will invoke
a native function
in our own JavaScript code
with whatever the payload is
for the response.
So we're basically
getting around
some of the cross-domain
limitations
that would normally
prevent you from, you know,
using something
like XML-HTTP requests
to directly, you know,
ask our servers
for a response.
And jQuery will make that
pretty easy.
jQuery, you know,
also just makes a lot
of other things easy as well.
And everything is JavaScript,
more or less.
I'll show you, you know,
the actual HTML source.
It's very short.
Most of--all--
most of the important things
are done
in the JavaScript section.
And we'll focus on some
specific sections there
in a second.
And there's, you know, CSS,
as you might imagine--
uh, very basic CSS styling.
One thing I did decide to do
was just use, uh, Web Fonts,
which are part of one of
the newer CSS specifications.
And I'm using
the Google Fonts API
just for pulling down something
a little bit flashier,
let's say,
than, um, the built-in fonts
that might be present
on a given user's computer.
So this is the example.
I have this open over here.
Uh, I want
to just quickly load up
the uploads feed
for the Google Developers
YouTube channel.
And Google Developers is
just a great channel in general
for having a variety
of different developer content.
So this is playing right away.
Ross: My name is Max Ross.
Posnick: And you see, you know,
these controls down here.
This is SVG, as I mentioned,
um, yeah, right now,
because for pause--
the pause button is disabled.
The play button is enabled.
Uh, these are
the slider controls
using <input type='range'>.
If I do start the playback,
we should be able
to toggle the volume.
Ross: I focus primarily on...
Posnick: And we should
also be able to use this
to jump to a different portion
of the video.
You know,
much as you'd imagine,
you have the current time
listed over here.
Um, just all the basic
type of controls
that you would normally see
in the YouTube player,
but implemented, you know,
completely with our own code.
And just to show you,
we can also jump
to the next video in the feed.
man: All right, hey, there.
Posnick: You can do that
pretty much indefinitely.
So just to show you really quick
the source,
uh, for the HTML.
Pretty straightforward--
it's just this page of code.
Um, most of logic,
as I said,
is done in JavaScript.
So I wanted to jump to that
and show you, uh,
just a little bit
of the JavaScript.
And particularly,
I wanted to focus
on the JavaScript that's used
to handle player events.
And, uh, this is
kind of what I found
the most, uh,
difficult to get correct.
And--and when I've worked
with developers in general,
um, and just spoken to folks,
I think this is
the hardest thing
to kind of wrap
your head around,
how to respond to the proper
YouTube player events.
And it's really key
if you're writing
a custom player experience
to get this right.
Otherwise you end up, um,
having, you know,
UI elements that are disabled
when, you know, they actually
need to be enabled
or just, you know,
not taking into account
the fact that an error has
happened and things like that.
So, uh, there are kind of
three main characters--
categories of events,
uh, that are handled
via the YouTube iframe API.
There's the onReady events.
Um, this is fired
when the player API
is initially available.
So if you wanted to do something
as soon as the player API
is available,
you know,
as Jarek mentioned before,
the iframe API
right now is, uh,
the way we recommend loading it
is asynchronously
so, uh, it doesn't necessarily--
it actually would not be
available
whenever, you know,
your DOM is fully available.
It's gonna be at some point
afterwards.
If you want to put in some code
that gets fired
only when everything
is fully ready,
you would put it
in your onReady handler.
The onError handler,
as the name suggests,
is something
that would get fired
whenever there's any sort
of playback error.
Um, for instance, if a video
is not playable
on your particular device
for any number of reasons,
uh, that will get fired.
It's pretty important
to put in some code
for--for handling that.
It might be as simple as moving
to the next video,
if you happen to have
a list of videos,
um, or displaying some sort
of error to the user.
But it definitely helps
the user experience
if you were to put in some code
to handle that.
And the third category of events
is onStateChange.
Uh, you can kind of think of it
as a catchall
that has a bunch of sub-events
for the different changes
in the YouTube player state.
And I wanted to focus most
of my time talking about that.
So kind of five main events,
uh, ENDED, PLAYING, PAUSED,
BUFFERING, and CUED.
As Jarek mentioned,
the BUFFERING event
won't be fired
for the HTML5 player now,
uh, but those other events
are all relevant.
And...
in general, um,
my recommendation
is just not to make assumptions
about the global state
of the player
or what triggered the events
in your event handler.
And you know,
one example
where somebody could go wrong
is they see that
the YT.PlayerState.PLAYING event
was fired in their event
state change handler.
And they figure, okay,
well, if that event was fired,
it must be because somebody
clicked on the play button.
But there's actually
a number of other ways
that playback can start
for a given video.
Um, the user might have clicked
on the actual
YouTube video itself,
which is something
that will trigger playback.
Or you know, as Greg
was illustrating before,
there are ways to use
keyboard controls
for, you know,
tabbing into a video
and starting playback.
So if you have
any specific assumptions
that are built around
the fact, okay,
somebody must have clicked
on the play button,
uh, they might be wrong
i-in your play handler.
So I would recommend,
uh, explicitly--
you know, especially when
you're changing the state
of other UI elements
in response to events,
I would recommend
to explicitly set the states
each time through
in your event change handlers
to whatever
the appropriate value
you know it should be
for that event,
rather than, you know, just,
like, toggling given elements.
Uh, and I think,
you know, that leads
to a much better
user experience.
So I wanted to get
into some code that, uh,
is relevant to that point,
and just a few
helper functions here
for enabling and disabling,
uh, a list of different elements
given their element names--
element ideas, rather--
and, uh, just a helper method
for setting up the, um,
the task that fires
in the background basically,
that updates
the current time in--
you know, what we saw
in the lower left corner
of the player--
the current playback time.
So we have, uh, something
that will set that up for us,
'cause we're gonna need to clear
that in certain circumstances
and then reestablish it later.
So this is just, uh,
some snippets of code,
uh, where you, for instance,
would handle
the CUED state events.
And this is what gets fired
when the player is load--
the video is loaded
into the player,
but playback hasn't
actually begun yet.
And in that scenario,
as you might expect,
you'd think,
okay, what controls
do I want to be enabled
in that case?
And you want the play button
to be enabled.
And what controls, you know,
just don't make sense
to have enabled?
You know, pause, volume,
and seek--
they're not gonna
be able to do anything
when you're in that CUED state.
So, um, you want
to explicitly change
those values to those states,
uh, each time
we get into the CUED state.
And something, you know,
very similar--
the thing
about the PAUSED state,
except there's gonna be
a different set of things
that you'd want to have enabled.
So you want
the play button enabled.
You want the volume controls
to still be enabled,
'cause you can still change
the volume of the video,
even though it's not playing.
And you'd still like the person
to be able to jump
to a different point
in the video,
so you want the seek bar
to still be enabled.
But you know, again,
you don't want the pause button
to be enabled,
because it certainly
doesn't make sense.
Uh, and you know,
and we're also gonna clear
the background time-out
that, uh, that would be fired
to update the player time,
because, you know,
if the video is paused,
we know that the time is
not gonna be increasing at all.
And PLAYING is in some respects
the opposite.
We want to enable
the pause button,
the volume button,
the seek button.
We want to re-create
that interval.
Uh, we want to set the volume
and the duration values
to whatever, uh, they are
by reading that
via the API call.
And you know, this might be
overriding the existing values.
There might already be a value
for the duration there,
or the volume
might already be equal
to whatever
the current volume is,
but it's--it's really not
gonna hurt anything
to set that again.
It might be wasting
a couple of CPU cycles,
but I've found it--
it just simplifies
things greatly
if you don't make
any assumptions
about what's already there
in the state,
and you explicitly set it.
And finally, ENDED--
very similar, uh,
to what we've seen before.
One thing I wanted to point
out... [clears throat]
Excuse me. One thing
I wanted to point out
is that it really makes
a difference, I've found,
to explicitly set
whatever the current time is
in the playback.
And that's the value
that you see over here.
This is the current time.
This is the duration.
Uh, once the video is over,
you want to make sure that
that current time is set
to the duration of the video.
Um, you know,
I'm pretty sure folks have had
the experience where you
reach the end of the video,
and maybe it's because
the video is not--
it has, like, a fractional
second in its duration,
and there's
some rounding involved,
and you know, it says
the video's four minutes,
but you're at--the display
says 3 minutes and 59 seconds,
and you're like, what?
What's in that secret
one last second of the video?
Obviously there's nothing there,
but it just leads
to a better user experience
to explicitly set that.
So that--
that's my recommendation
for handling the ENDED state.
And yeah, that's--
that's kind of an overview
of, um, some of the JavaScript
in the example.
Definitely feel free
to take a look
and explore some more.
I want to remind folks
that we have those--
excuse me.
We have those hash tags--
#io2011 and #YouTube--
for this session.
And if you have any feedback,
you can go to that URL as well.
And we want to take
any questions
you guys might have
either about iframe player API
or YouTube topics in general.
And hopefully we'll have
some answers for you.
Schechter: Um,
before we jump into questions,
I actually want to promote--
we've got this awesome
after-party coming up.
Um, and so YouTube's
one of the main sponsors for it.
It's at Thirsty Bear. You can
come grab tickets from us.
And one thing that's
really important
is there's a QR code
on the back.
If you, uh, scan it
and register ahead of time,
uh, you'll get to skip
the line to go in.
So hopefully you'll join us
tonight for that.
man: I have
a quick question for you.
Um, I've used the iframe player
a little bit.
Um, is there a way to--
whether it's Flash or HTML5
that's being exposed on the--
on the client side,
is there a way to, um,
set the window mode
to transparent
or interact with the CSS
of the, uh,
the HTML5 video player?
Schechter: Uh, yeah,
so, um, you can add wmode
as one of the arguments
in the, uh, URL.
So that way you'll interact
with Flash,
and then you can just interact,
uh, with the iframe with CSS
like you normally would,
um, for--
if it's the HTML5 player.
man: Okay,
so with the oEmbed endpoint,
I know that you can add
that parameter
to get the iframe code returned.
Um, are there plans to start
returning the iframe code
by default
on the oEmbed endpoint,
or not in the foreseeable
future?
Posnick: Yeah, um,
we actually recently made
a slight change
to the oEmbed endpoint
that ended up breaking
a lot of folks,
and that was just changing
one character in the URL.
So I think we're--
I personally would advocate
that we don't make too many
changes to our defaults
and continue to allow, uh, folks
to explicitly request things
in the hopes of not breaking
too many existing
implementations.
Uh, that's--
that's my personal preference.
I'm not the one actually
responsible for the service.
But that's what I'm hoping.
Wilkiewicz: One issue
that we've seen
is, uh, you know,
people, uh, build platforms
that don't allow iframes.
And then--so the iframe
actually has to be white-listed.
And that has been kind of
the number one source of pain
as we were rolling it out
and working
with a lot of the, you know,
say, blogging platforms,
provider, uh, you know, sites,
and so forth,
so that they will actually
allow this--this iframe.
And we've made
a lot of progress,
but, uh, there's a lot more
work to do, yeah.
man: Uh, hey, guys,
I had a question
about the accuracy
of the, uh,
the skip-to
and skip-ahead function.
Um, I noticed
during the caption talk
that was in here earlier,
um, that there was
fractional seconds involved
for the start time
and the end time
for a given piece of text.
Uh, my question is
are there plans
to make it more accurate
as far as the skip-ahead,
skip-back,
um, just to make
navigational control
a little bit easier,
or to be more accurate
with, uh, any sort
of external navigation
we can develop?
Schechter: Uh, so one
of the nice things about HTML5
is we actually don't have
that issue.
Um, so with Flash you're
worried about, uh, key frames
and having to jump
to a key frame.
Uh, HTML5 just standard--
just goes to the time
that you specified.
Uh, so you'll have
that accuracy that you want.
man: Um, can you--can you do,
like, fractional seconds
or, uh, anything like that?
Schechter: I, uh,
I haven't tried it.
man: All right.
Schechter: Um... I don't know.
man: Cool, thanks.
man: Hi, guys.
Uh, the API documentation
says that the iframe player API
is currently not ready
for mission
or business-critical
applications.
Uh, I was wondering when,
uh, what the time frame
for--for that to be removed is,
that restriction.
Posnick: Yeah, I don't think
we have an exact time frame.
This discussion comes up a lot.
Uh, I think just...
the important thing to realize
is it's still a work
in development,
and you know,
in the course of me writing
this demo application,
I know I've held
about half a dozen bugs
against, uh,
against Greg...
Schechter: Right.
Posnick: to--to resolve.
So I-I think, um, you know,
it's not there yet,
and hopefully
that does not stop folks
from using it
in their either, you know,
"non-mission-critical"
environments
or just trying to develop
against it
in parallel to whatever
the existing thing is.
And definitely file bugs.
Let us know in, uh,
the Google group in particular.
I think that's the best way
of getting in touch with us.
And you know,
Greg is super responsive
about, uh, getting things fixed.
And you know,
as we get to a point,
I think, where there are
fewer and fewer reports
of things going wrong,
we'll have a greater confidence
in, uh, you know,
taking off that label
and being able to say,
you know,
it should be as--
as supported as our AS3 embed.
man: All right, thank you.
man: What's the timeline
on, uh, getting iOS support
with the autoplay?
I know that's an Apple issue
and not, you know,
an iframe issue.
Wilkiewicz: Yeah.
man: But when you've talked
to the team,
have they given you a sense
of why they've disabled autoplay
on the iframe player?
And is there an E.T.A.
for getting that fixed?
Do you see
a resolution happening?
Wilkiewicz: So we--you know,
we work very closely with Apple.
They're obviously driving
a lot of our playbacks.
And, uh, actually if you look
at the documentation closely,
uh, for the video playback,
it states that, uh,
for 3G environments,
uh, the user interaction
is required.
And you know, I--personally,
I kinda, you know, buy that.
man: Right.
Wilkiewicz: Uh, but then,
on Wi-Fi, uh, you know,
maybe it should be
a little more liberal.
And in fact, this is what
we've been trying to, uh,
to see if, uh,
the team at Apple
could--could add that.
But I don't have an E.T.A.
But you know,
we have filed a--
and there has been
a request for that.
And we work very closely.
You know,
they're a good partner.
man: Gotcha. But they seem
favorable to the idea
that autoplaying in theory
would make sense
on a Wi-Fi connection?
Wilkiewicz: Uh, you know,
I-I wouldn't go as far
as saying
that they are favorable.
Uh, but you know, if you cannot
look a the user documentation
from our perspective,
uh, there's a discrepancy
in behavior.
Or you know, the Wi-Fi behavior
is unspecified.
So if it is unspecified,
perhaps we could, uh,
make it work just like what--
what we described.
I think that would be
probably the best solution
for application developers
and carriers
and everybody else
involved, yeah.
man: Sure. Um, I guess,
on the YouTube app,
that's, you know,
native to the device--
and as I understand it,
Apple built that, not YouTube.
Um, is there some work-around
that you can envision that,
if you're building
a native iOS app,
you'd be able to support
the autoplayback?
Or is there kind of no--
no work-around?
Wilkiewicz: So for native
iOS apps
that incorporate
YouTube Video Playback,
there's really three approaches
that you can take
for video embedding.
One is you can kick off
the, um, YouTube player, right?
So that's one.
The other one is, um,
you can use the existing
Flash embed,
and what iOS does is recognizes,
oh, this is a YouTube embed,
and then uses a Safari plug-in
in order to play back the video.
And this is where
this approach falls apart,
if you build
your own Flash player
and no longer can, you know--
iOS recognizes the signature,
and then you get a black box.
And the third approach
is the, uh, iframe embed.
So, um, if you build
a native iOS application,
uh, you can actually use
UIWebView
and embed the AS3 embed
or the, uh, iframe embed,
and then, uh,
iOS would recognize it.
In one case it uses
the Safari plug-in.
In the other cases it uses
HTML5, uh, Video Playback.
The HTML5 Video Playback
has the advantage
of actually having
an API around it.
So I know more
and more application developers
are using the iframe API
for iOS applications
because it is
the only game in town.
So even though, you know,
technically we're saying
that, hey,
it's not mission-critical,
but, uh, the argument
we're making--
it's still better
than nothing, you know.
So you can actually do
something.
man: Yeah.
Wilkiewicz: So--so that's
kind of the story that we have.
But I think all of them suffer
from the same
fundamental limitation
when it comes to autoplay.
man: Yeah, I've seen
some hacky solutions
where you can fire
a touch event,
and then you kind of crawl the--
the player,
then find out
what the play button is,
then you send a touch event,
which, you know,
apparently isn't allowed
by the documentation,
but they've let apps
kind of do it.
Wilkiewicz: I see.
man: Is there any other
solution beyond that
that--that works,
or is that kind of the only--
only thing for autoplay
using iOS?
Wilkiewicz: Uh, yeah,
so we don't have anything that
we support right now for that.
man: Good. Thanks.
man: Hey, so I have a habit
of putting Linux on old laptops.
And then, uh,
at previous companies
I was always--always trying
to get, you know,
real movies
playing on old hardware.
Is the performance
of HTML5 video
so much better than Flash
that, like,
it really makes it possible
to watch movies
on old hardware?
Schechter: Um, it's--
it's sort of
a little bit tricky.
So, uh, when the encodings
are in H.264,
uh, the performance
is generally a little bit
better than HTML5,
although I don't have
any numbers to give you.
Uh, WebM--I usually don't see
performance being as good,
because, uh, you don't have
a specialized chip for it.
Um, but you know, they're making
a lot of improvements there.
Uh, but also the--
a lot of--
a lot of what we've been
doing on WebM--
uh, it's got, uh, less bytes
for the same amount of quality.
Um, and so, you know,
it's a better--
we think that it's
a better encoding.
But yeah, we're still
sort of, uh, struggling
on making sure
that the performance
of, like, the CPU
is gonna be equal or better.
Cool.
Posnick: Okay, um,
doesn't look
like there are
any more questions.
So thanks, you guys,
for coming.
Schechter: Thank you.
[applause]